i watch Beverly Hills housewives  religiously I heard grandi on your show  she does think I hate her I think and do  you know the issue with Brandi was that  she got isolated to a point over two  seasons where she would admit also she  was on an island and she is it now in a  place where none of them want to be with  her they won't they didn't want to hang  out with their Housewives come to you  say look we can work on more with her no  no no not the case they don't will they  yes they may say that but it won't what  happens all the time  that happens all the time yet they  genuinely hate her they yeah and I and  by the way Brandi hates them are you  gonna bring her back a little bit would  love to yes I love to and by the way but  what do you mean if you would love to  then isn't it a done deal I hope so